your majesty if you watch the
documentary
so no response from the King there and
actually we haven't heard anything from
members of the royal family ever since
those trailers have been released over
the last week I think they are very much
trying to keep their heads down carry on
with the engagements as one Palace
Insider told me yesterday the queen
always had this Mantra don't look at
your feet look at the Horizon and that I
think is what members of the royal
family are going to do but in terms of
these first three episodes of this this
documentary series no I don't think
there are the kind of level of damning
allegations that we saw within Oprah but
this is Harry it seems Unleashed still
on a crusade to show that they were
unfairly treated by the UK press they
were unfairly treated by members of the
royal family and ultimately I think the
couple have paid the price haven't they
they've taken the money from Netflix and
now they were expected to give an awful
lot when it comes to recording and
documenting what they think happened to
them